to do what you do
because even in the moment when you come
out
you're calm
you know it's not like so so
i go back to like my my belief system
for capitalism
people always cares you know where the
hell does that come from like what do
you out of your mind like
why would you be such a proponent of
capitalism because i grew up communist
and i grew up in a family so if you go
back down to my lineage and you find out
what prompted this level of belief
system to see that i don't like the
concept of manipulation and pinning
people against each other where the guys
that are creating the jobs that are bad
guys all the time i'm sorry i have a
hard time with that i got a very hard
time with them so that stayed sure since
as a kid so there's nothing for you that
happened where you're like i'm gonna
catch the bad guy very little bullying
no victimization nothing like that but
i always always always
felt a need to stick up for those who
are being picked upon
i always felt very fortunate fighting
for the little guy i always felt very
fortunate to be in this body and again
to not
you know you know
be wealthy or anything but to to as a
kid but but to be comfortable yeah i
never worried about anything i mean i
worked and i did my part and i you know
those are great experiences for me
to understand hard work to be
in a different group of people to
understand what it was like to come from
the south and work your way up and be in
detroit and make it and make a decent
wage
uh and to hear stories of how that
happened
in a truly urban life
you know we used to listen to different
radio stations that i would hear when i
was in high school working in the
summers hauling drywall it made me a
good reporter it made me
it gave me the ability to go into the
inner city
and be able to connect with people and
have an immediate level of trust where
they would talk to me people who i
didn't know it's not an easy task it's
not an easy task but it's it's a
combination i think
of a genuine sense of curiosity
september 13th september 13th yeah why
are you so curious pat because pat
you've asked that question quite
candidly to a lot of people yeah
but it's a good question for chris
hanson you're like no i really am
genuinely curious about this one no no
no
okay so let's just say nbc calls you
today saying you're the next guy to go
do the show catching a predator you want
to do that job
no i'm being honest with you i'm being
honest i don't know if i want that life
do you understand what i'm saying to you
there's how many people watching and
saying oh you know what sign me up yeah
i mean hanson's here cancel the party no
it's not even that it's the job
uh
it gets eyeballs but do you really want
to have the to do that job there's got
to be a certain level of true belief to
say i'm i want to go do this because i
want to correct an injustice that's why
we said that about james o'keefe it's
like do you want that life what he's
doing he's very noble yeah and
hard-hitting and investigative and he's
all about himself what does he call
himself the muckraker muckraker that's
what he does
you think you think he's got an easy
life you think he goes to sleep uh
you know gets his eight hours of sleep
every night okay you know james will
keep project verified yeah so that's
that's not an easy life no it's not
that's why i'm asking a question to see
what was the wiring who was the
individual you know that's the part that
makes the story interesting folks here's
what i want to talk to today uh with
chris chris
there's a few things that's on my mind
so one
i'm a parent i got four kids i'm
concerned okay my kids are ten eight
five and eight months okay and i watched
i watched a movie called disconnect i
don't know if you've seen it or not if
you haven't seen it i'll tell you the
premise of the story and if the audience
hasn't seen it it's mind-boggling i
think every parent needs to watch this
movie it doesn't have the highest scores
it's not like
a movie that won awards but if you're a
parent do yourself a favor put this on
the list go watch it this weekend and if
your kids are old enough i'm going to
watch this thing with my kids in about a
couple years i'm going to watch this
with my kids i'm preparing them for them
to watch these kids i want to talk about
uh kanye and t.i a part of t.i is the
fact that how protective he is with his
daughter every year the fear of a father
to go check to see if she's a virgin or
not i don't know if you're worried this
story no i've read about it yeah so we
can talk about that and kanye and pete
davidson right now with kim going back
and forth what is the effect of that on
the kids because is there anything that
they're doing that's hurting the kids
and they're not realizing it how
public they've made it and you know
tinder
bumble some of these dating sites today
the other day adam's uh uh famous for
swiping right he doesn't need to but
he's famous for swiping right this
weekend this was leo's birthday right
happy 40th birthday to leo
we go to bodega and i'm like thinking
we're going to la solas we end up going
to miami hour drive and i go in there
there's 20 girls around adam i mean it's
like girls are just enamored with this
guy handsome he's a handsome fellow
thanks guys yeah compliments will get
you everywhere but here's what happened
to him last week tinder which he called
me at two o'clock in the morning
shivering he was nervous
tinder apparently he swiped right with
somebody where they sent you a message
and they said what to you
well it was on hinge but yeah
and uh you're serious unhinged yeah i
was like oh i keep thinking
but it's all nonetheless yeah they they
gave me a warning saying someone you've
connected to we've identified as being a
fraudulent individual
you know disclaimer alert dot dot dot be
careful with and it actually intrigued
me more i was like well hold on let me
let me find out more about this yeah
but uh shall we cancel if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]